CELEBRITY APPRENTICE SEVERAL
YEARS AGO.
SHE OFFERED HIM SEX IN ORDER
TO WIN AND ATTACKED HIM AND
HIS FAMILY WHEN HE TURNED IT
DOWN.
SOUNDS SEEDY AND WEIRD, OF
COURSE IT IS.
STILL NOT THE STRANGEST
THING HAPPENING IN
WASHINGTON RIGHT NOW.
TONIGHT WE HAVE MORE ON THE
ONGOING SAGA OF THE TRUMP
DOSSIER.
SENATORS CHUCK GRASSLEY AND
LINDSEY GRAHAM HAVE LAUNCHED
A PROBE INTO FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR SUSAN RICE.
IN THE VERY FINAL MINUTES OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
JUST AFTERNOON ON
SENT HERSELF AN EMAIL ON THE
WHITE HOUSE COMPUTER SYSTEM.
IN IT SHE DESCRIBES A
MEETING SHE HAD ATTENDED
JUST TWO WEEKS BEFORE ON
JANUARY 5TH.
AT THAT MEETING WERE
PRESIDENT OBAMA, VICE
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN, FBI
DIRECTOR JIM COMEY, DEPUTY
A.G. SALLY YATES AND SUSAN
RICE HERSELF.
ACCORDING TO RICE IN THIS
EMAIL, OBAMA INSTRUCTED THE
OFFICIALS IN THE ROOM TO
CONSIDER WITHHOLDING
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE FROM
THE INCOMING TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN CASE THEY
WERE COMPROMISED BY RUSSIA.
IN OTHER WORDS, ALMOST TWO
MONTHS AFTER THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION,
BARACK OBAMA VIEWED TRUMP
NOT AS HIS DEMOCRATICALLY
ELECTED SUCCESSOR BUT AS A
TRAITOR AND A RUSSIAN SPY.
OBAMA VIEWED HIMSELF AS
SOMEONE WHO SOMEHOW HAD THE
RIGHT TO WITHHOLD GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS FROM AN ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S NOT THE BEHAVIOR OF
SOMEONE WHO BELIEVES IN
DEMOCRACY.
AND, YET, THAT MEETING SET
THE TONE FOR THAT YEAR AND
ALL SUBSEQUENT ARGUMENTS
SINCE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TREATED TRUMP
AND HIS ELECTIONS AS
ILLEGITIMATE EVER SINCE
THEN.
CASE AGAINST TRUMP AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS THE STEELE
DOT YEA.
SO THIS DAY THE DOSSIER IS
THE ONLY PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
DOCUMENT THAT DETAILS
ALLEGED COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA.
NOW, OF COURSE, WE HAVE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE
DOSSIER ON THIS PROGRAM.
BUT RELATIVELY LITTLE ABOUT
WHAT IS IN IT.
WHAT DOES THE DOSSIER
ACTUALLY CLAIM?
IS ANY OF IT TRUE?
AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR OF
PROBING BY POLITICIANS AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND
JOURNALISTS, HERE'S THE SUM
TOTAL OF WHAT WE ACTUALLY
KNOW ABOUT THE DOCUMENT THAT
STARTED ALL OF THIS.
WE KNOW THE DOSSIER WAS
COMPILED BY CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, ACTING AS A
CONTRACTOR OF FUSION G.P.S.
WITH FUNDS SUPPLIED BY THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND
THE DNC.
THE DOSSIER WAS A FORM OF
OPPOSITION RESEARCH DESIGNED
TO BE USED AGAINST TRUMP IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS NOT AN INTELLIGENCE
DOCUMENT.
IT WAS OPPO.
THE DOSSIER CLAIMS THAT
RUSSIAN AUTHORITIES DIDN'T
SIMPLY COLLUDE WITH TRUMP
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION,
THE CHARGE YOU HEAR A LOT
ABOUT.
IT ALSO CLAIMS THAT RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE CULTIVATED
DONALD TRUMP AS A KIND OF
ASSET, A KIND OF ONE-MAN
SLEEPER CELL FOR MORE THAN
FIVE YEARS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
THE DOSSIER ALSO CLAIMS THE
KREMLIN FED THE TRUMP TEAM
INTEL REPORTS ON HILLARY
CLINTON AND OTHER POLITICAL
OPPONENTS FOR YEARS.
THERE'S NO PROOF OF THAT
EITHER.
IT CLAIMS TRUMP WAS FAVORED
BY MOSCOW WITH LUCRATIVE
RUSSIAN REAL ESTATE DEALS AS
PART OF HIS CULTIVATION AS A
POLITICAL ASSET.
THAT SLEEPER CELL.
NO PROOF THERE EITHER.
ACCORDING TO THE DOSSIER,
TRUMP AND RUSSIA WERE
EXCHANGING INTELLIGENCE WITH
EACH OTHER FOR AT LEAST 8
YEARS NO.
PROOF OF THAT THE DOSSIER
GOES ON TO DESCRIBE THE
CLANDESTINED MEETING IN
PRAGUE BETWEEN MICHAEL COHEN
AND REPRESENTATIVES THAT
SUPPOSEDLY TOOK PLACE IN
AUGUST OF 2016.
THIS IS ONE OF THE VERY FEW
CLAIMS IN THE DOSSIER THAT
HAS BEEN CONCLUSIVELY
CHECKED AND IT'S FALSE.
COHEN WASN'T EVEN OUTSIDE
THE U.S. AT THE TIME THE
MEETING SUPPOSEDLY TOOK
PLACE.
IN SUM, THE STEELE DOSSIER
IS ABSURD.
THE CLOSER YOU READ IT, THE
MORE ABSURD IT IS.
TAKE 10 MINUTES TO DO SO
YOURSELF.
IT'S ONLINE.
AS YOU READ IT, ASK YOURSELF
WHO WOULD BELIEVE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS?
IT'S SO TRANSPARENTLY
PARTISAN AND UNLIKELY AND
STUPID AND FLIMSY, IT READS
LIKE A PARODY OF A BADLY
WRITTEN SPY NOVEL.
AT THE SAME TIME HE WAS
FIRING PEOPLE ON THE
APPRENTICE, DONALD TRUMP WAS
WORKING WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN
TO SUBVERT AMERICA?
IT'S HARD EVEN TO SAY THAT
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE.
IT'S THAT STUPID.
YET, KEEP IN MIND AND NEVER
FORGET, THIS IS THE DOCUMENT
THE FBI USED TO JUSTIFY
SPYING ON AMERICAN CITIZENS.
THESE ARE THE CLAIMS THAT
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
REPEATEDLY CITED AS THE
REASON TO STOP THE NORMAL
FUNCTIONING OF GOVERNMENT IN
ORDER TO INVESTIGATE THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS THE FAMOUS DOSSIER
THAT EVEN TODAY PROGRESSIVES
IN THE MEDIA ARE SPENDING
CORROBORATE.
AND IT'S ALL A STUPID JOKE.
AMAZINGLY A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
POWER FELL FOR IT.
CONGRESSMAN RON DESANTIS IS
A REPUBLICAN REPRESENTING
THE STATE OF FLORIDA AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
>> GOOD EVENING.
>> Tucker: THE MEETING THAT
SUSAN RICE DESCRIBES HAD HER
EMAIL THE VICE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT SALLY YATES
AND COMEY IS REALLY
REVEALING.
TRUMP WAS ACCUSED OF
CONSIDERING OBAMA FOREIGN
WITH THE BIRTHER STUFF.
OBAMA DID CONSIDER TRUMP
FOREIGN, A FOREIGN AGENT.
CAN A SITTING PRESIDENT DENY
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS,
PRESIDENT?
>> I DON'T SEE HOW YOU CAN
DO THAT.
I MEAN, JUST THINK ABOUT
WHAT YATES WAS ON TO AT THE
TIME WITH MICHAEL FLYNN MET
WITH KISLYAK, THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY SHE SENT THE FBI AGENTS
TO FLYNN ONCE HE GOT IN.
SO THEY WERE CREATING SOME
TYPE OF BOOGIE MAN REALLY
OUT OF FLYNN ACTING LIKE ANY
INCOMING NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR WOULD.
>> Tucker: A PRESIDENT'S
AUTHORITY AND LEGITIMACY
COMES FROM VOTERS WINNING AN
ELECTION.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES YOU THE
PRESIDENT.
HOW CAN ONE PRESIDENT SAY I
DON'T THINK THE NEXT GUY
SHOULD HAVE THIS.
I DON'T THINK IS HE WORTHY
OF THIS INFORMATION.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPROPER TO
DO THAT.  IT'S INTERESTING.
THIS JANUARY 5TH MEETING IN
THE OVAL WITH COMEY, WHAT
DID COMEY DO THAT VERY NEXT
DAY?
THAT WAS WHEN HE BRIEFED
TRUMP ON THE DOSSIER.
HE WENT TO TRUMP TOWER.
HE SHOWED HIM THE DOSSIER.
THAT EVENTUALLY GOT LEAKED
TO CNN AND THEN THAT ALLOWED
THE DOSSIER TO GET PUT OUT
INTO THE BLOODSTREAM.
ALSO, DURING THIS WHOLE
TRANSITION TIME HAVE YOU AN
UNPRECEDENTED CAMPAIGN OF
LEAKING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION DESIGNED TO PUT
A CLOUD OVER TRUMP'S
INCOMING PRESIDENCY.
SO I THINK SUSAN RICE HAS A
LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT SHE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO ANSWER.
WHY WOULD YOU ALL OF A
SUDDEN RIGHT AS YOU ARE
LEAVING THE WHITE HOUSE DO
THAT EMAIL SAYING OBAMA SAID
DO IT BY THE BOOK?
IT'S JUST A REALLY ODD THING
TO DO.
SHE WAS TRYING TO CREATE A
RECORD AND THE QUESTION IS
WHY DID SHE FEEL THE NEED TO
DO THAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S THE
ANSWER?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO FIND
OUT THE ANSWER.
I THINK IT WAS CLEAR THAT BY
THE TIME TRUMP GOT
INAUGURATED, I MEAN, YOU HAD
THE PERMANENT BUREAUCRACY IN
THE OBAMA HOLDOVERS.
THEY WERE PUTTING, FEEDING
INFORMATION TO THE PRESS ON
A DAILY BASIS.
THE FIRST TWO OR THREE
MONTHS OF HIS ADMINISTRATION
WAS CONSTANT BOMBSHELL
REPORTS, QUOTE, UNQUOTE, ALL
BASED ON ANONYMOUS SOURCES,
ALL BASED ON FORMER OR
CURRENT U.S. OFFICIALS.
AND THAT REALLY STARTED FROM
THE DAY HE GOT ELECTED ALL
THE WAY UNTIL THE
APPOINTMENT OF ROBERT
MUELLER AS SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> Tucker: THE DOSSIER
ITSELF WHICH IS THE CENTER
THE PUBLIC CONSUMPTION
CLAIMS THAT TRUMP WAS BEING
CULTIVATED BY RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE FOREVER FIVE
YEARS PRIOR TO BECOMING
PRESIDENT IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT'S TRUE?
>> NO EVIDENCE THAT THAT'S
TRUE.
THINK ABOUT EVEN WHAT THEY
USED FOR CARTER PAGE.
I MEAN, THE IDEA THAT THE
RUSSIAN OIL COMPANY --
ENERGY COMPANY WAS GOING TO
GIVE HIM 10% STAKE OR 20%
STAKE IN A COMPANY THAT IS
SO BIG THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
$10 BILLION THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO GIVE TO CARTER PAGE
AND THE FBI USED THAT TO GET
SURVEILLANCE.
SO THE ONLY THING THAT HAS
DEFINITELY BEEN CORROBORATED
IS THAT CARTER PAGE DID
TRAVEL TO RUSSIA DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
DID HE THAT.
HE GAVE A PUBLIC SPEECH.
NONE OF THE OTHER KEY FACTS
HAVE BEEN CORROBORATED AT
ALL.
>> Tucker: NOT SURPRISINGLY.
AM I OVERSTATING IT WHEN I
SAY AS A NORMAL PERSON
READINGS THE DOSSIER IT
SEEMS PRIMA FACIE ABSURD.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE A MORON
TO TAKE THAT AT FACE VALUE.
>> THAT'S MY REACTION TO IT
IT'S SPECTACULAR AND
SOMETHING THAT COMEY WAS
ACTUALLY RIGHT ABOUT.